[Musique]
j'ai une entreprise de production de
charbon qui se situe dans les haau du
Maïo et une deuxième usine qui se situe
dans les haut du tevlav j'ai créé une
marque donc qui se nomme Tom Tom
grilloduire le charbon j'ai dû faire un
partenariat avec l'Office National des
Forêts qui m'a beaucoup aidé en me
fournissant toute la matière première
donc ça provient de l'incendie du Maido
qui s'est déroulé il me semble en
[Musique]
2010 mon travail est de récupérer tout
ce qui a brûlé d'une part et puis de
nettoyer euh toute la forêt et enlever
tout ce qui a brûlé pour pouvoir
produire du charbon suite à mon passage
le NF pourra revenir et puis reggénérer
une nouvelle
forêt je perpituer une tradition dans le
temps maison le M transmis le
savoir-faire du moins du charbon et puis
euh moi j'ai apporté ma petite touche
personnelle en mod an un peu la
production et pour pouvoir faire plus de
volume le charbon se faisait sous terre
maintenant c'est cuit dans des
cuves ça sera un charbon avec un volume
plus gros donc des plus gros morceaux et
qui produisent moins de send à la
combustion donc ben c'est qui fournit
une meilleure qualité et avec un bois
qui est très connu à la Réunion c'est le
bois d'acasscia et le bois de Tamarin
qui est déjà à la base un bois de très
bonne
[Musique]
qualité avant de monter mon entreprise
donc je travaillis dans la grande
distribution j'ai pas eu vraiment une
place qui correspondait à mes diplômes
donc j'ai décidé de de me lancer dans
une entreprise avec l'aide de la die et
de la Boutique de gestion qui m'ont aidé
à mettre en place tout ce qu'il fallait
pour pouvoir démarrer
l'entreprise pour le montage des
dossiers les demandes de financement ça
m'a été d'une très grande
aide d'un point de vue technique même
était assez compliqué pour pouvoir
trouver les matériels adéquates et avoir
un apport aussi donc j'ai dû travailler
entretemps essayer d'avoir un capital
c'est venu petit à petit et puis ben ça
se développe encore maintenant j'ai
actuellement trois salariés je compte
embucher encore quelquesuns parce que
Ben suite à la demande très forte faudra
forcément embucher à un moment
donné j'ai connu Thomas ben il y a très
longtemps parce que on fait du sport
ensemble il y a un an que je travaille
avec lui j'ai vu comment il a ouvert son
entreprise c'est un travail bien et
c'est un travail très physique rigole
bien ai c'est ça le travail après il
faut un peu
rigoler j'aimerais pouvoir investir dans
l'entreprise et pouvoir augmenter le la
capacité de production en investissant
dans dans de nouveaux matériels c'est ce
que le challenge va m'apporter c'est ça
et après Ben qui dit augmentation de
production sera forcément ben créer de
nouveaux emplois à la Réunion et voilà
étendre la production pour que pour que
je puisse avoir encore de nouveaux
[Musique]
clients